you may have seen a previous video where
I proved how truly manly I was but
people still weren't convinced and
attempted to ridicule Me by calling me
feminine so I felt like it was once
again time to prove that I'm possibly
the most manliest man alive in the
kitchen instead of using a peeler for my
carrots I use a power sander with a 36
grit silicon carbide abrasive belt when
I make vegan keys from scratch I never
put on oven mitts and use a 6 and 1/2 in
circular saw to cut myself a big old
trucker slice like a real man when it's
finally time to shave your facial pubes
what do you use a razor like some s h
figures I use a pack ax sharper than a
Vermont cheddar on laundry day I don't
walk around with a basket and bend over
to pick up my clothes hell no I use a 12
amp 190 mph leaf blower all dudes love
getting a good facial that's for sure
but I use dry time indicator lightweight
joint compound that goes on pink dries
white so I know exactly how long to keep
it on and can have the smoothest most
Supple skin being anti-woman or using
femininity as an insult doesn't make you
a man it makes you a misogynist and it
reeks of insecurity